Oh
relationship between market and radicals
being a copy concerned by people for
many years I think the market does not
curl morality in modern world there are
only two types of economic and economic
systems the market economy in a planned
economy except you feel small countries
in Africa most countries in the modern
world are in market economy on the other
hand there was the Soviet camp in China
which adopted a planned economy for
decades she goes over the past several
centuries the word has sent in many ways
in which connected free market Spurs
maturity and a social progress while at
the same time strengthening moral
character using machine that the shield
the planet called me as a counterpart of
the market economy was created in the
20th century it was created in Soviet
Union in it then became an economic
model adopted by China in Eastern
European socialist countries the history
has shown us that the people under the
planned economy has lived under economic
stagnation shrinking of civil society in
the morrow morality crowding in recent
decades as the planned economies
collapse and their own contradictions
this is hopping experiment has proved to
be a systematic failure the citizens who
have endured long years of economic
model in a political disaster or eager
to get rid of it
of course the market economy is not a
perfect system the reason to financial
crisis in the United States suggest that
too but this does not imply that the
free market is going to bankrupt on the
contrary that suggests that when the
market economy develops its own new
transactions we new regulations it could
be say that the problems appear in a
free market originated from the
motivation and actions of people but not
from the market system itself in the
past century the human society have
improved market rules successfully these
experiences told us that if we talk
about the relationship between market
and morality without consideration of
social institution it's going to be
meaningless the human society is
sustained by political social and
economic cultural institutions in
different societies people the laws and
the moralities are different therefore
in different societies people have
different morality and then the
different morality in a shape people's
market behavior generally speaking free
market assist is associated with a free
society and in free society market
economy promote trust business and the
development economy but not croats
morality if we want to analyze the
relationship between market and morality
might be necessary to define the market
is a set of rules to coordinate economic
activities so when we make some moral
judgment about specific social economic
activities it should not be mixed up
with the moral judgment about market
rules
the toxic food problem is the result of
the morality collapse up in China when
the market economy liberate chinese
producers from the plan economy itself
does not necessarily produce or brought
about the collapse of morality it is
this corrupt government the
irresponsible states that caused the
collapse at morality in a causing the
problem of widespread toxic much food
problems historically morality has close
relationship with religion the protest
entities in Britain greatly influence
people's behavior and before the commons
party ruled China Chinese people
believed Buddhist Natalia Zea the
Buddhist emphasized that people have
better do good things but not bad things
otherwise they're going to be punished
by the god Shai busy awesome God the
body therefore such belief restoring
people's behavior so they do less they
get less bad things I believe this is a
reasonable explanation because in other
installation countries like Singapore in
Taiwan we can find that people who have
believed in more religious tend to be
more honest in business in the latter
half of 20th century in China the
commons party ruled this country and it
believes a census in abandoned any
religion and then the connors regime
carried out a serious political campaign
to prevent people believe any religions
in the series of political campaigns the
Chinese government to encourage people
to be informers for the party in other
words people are encouraged to report
the behavior in a speech of their
friends lovers and family members to the
party nothing could be worse than this
kind of encouraging
informers that would crowd the morality
of society
based on China's recent experience I'll
conclude with three important lessons
first the despite all the celebratory
coverage in the international press the
Chinese government's influence on the
market has not been unconditionally
positive yeah second a sustainable in a
strong market requires a demócrata
litical structure 3rd the su numero
development is no less important to a
task for China the encouraging economic
development